[Music]
there's no magic formula that will
guarantee you fame in popularity some
people spend their entire lives chasing
Fame while others become household names
and see their net worth skyrocket in the
strangest ways many kids have realized
it doesn't always take talent to become
a celebrity with a little bit of luck
they've seen their lives change
overnight if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we'll be sharing 10 kids who got famous
in the weirdest ways just wait until you
see the teenager who became an overnight
celebrity thanks to his awesome sense of
style lauren grey lauren gray also known
as Lauren beech became a social media
celebrity after she signed up for the
app musically back in 2015 the app
allows users to record short videos and
share them with their friends every day
millions of people use the app to
express themselves and their creativity
to their followers most people have
their family and friends following them
on the social media platform but for
Lauren she now has millions of people
who follow her and can't wait for her
next lip synching video to be released
she eventually migrated to Instagram to
show off her beautiful selfies and she
was able to gain over 5 million
followers she even caught the attention
of some big-name brands and she signed
on to a modeling agency she's reportedly
raking in the dough from online
advertisements and her modeling gigs her
net worth is estimated at $300,000 her
followers just can't get enough of her
and it's more than just her fun
lip-syncing videos and her gorgeous
pictures that lead people enchanted she
also had a pretty complicated love life
with a fellow social media star named
Joey kiss luck and that brings us to the
next famous kid on our list
Joey kiss luck you probably know Joey
kiss luck by his social media name why
not Joey just like his ex-girlfriend
Lauren gray he became famous by sharing
his videos on musically and he's also
one of the most
when he signed up for musically back in
2015 he was just 15 years old and he had
no idea how much his life would change
he later launched his own Twitter and
Instagram accounts and his fans were
more than happy to follow him wherever
he went on the Internet
but Joey soon realized that even though
he was a social media star he would have
to deal with the same issues that real
celebrities deal with - he was in a
long-term relationship with Lauren and
the two of them were so cute together
they even launched their own couples
Instagram page called Joey X Lauren they
shared lovey-dovey photos throughout the
relationship to their 100 thousand
followers but suddenly things changed
for the couple
Joey was forced to send out an
announcement on Twitter to let their
friends know that their relationship was
completely over he has since moved on
and his social media fans have found it
difficult to embrace his new girlfriend
they're still holding out hope for a
reconciliation but for now he seems to
be focused on his new relationship and
his career as a social-media influencer
Jordan woods when your best friend is
Kylie Jenner you can tag along to some
of the hottest parties in Hollywood and
rub elbows with some of the hottest
celebs
but Jordan woods wasn't content with
being Kylie's sidekick for the rest of
her life she wanted to branch out on her
own and become a star in her own right
thanks to her connection to the reality
TV star she was able to gain attention
online and rack up millions of Instagram
followers she has now launched her own
career that's bringing in the big bucks
aside from being a social-media
influencer she also signed a modeling
contract with Wilhemina curve and she's
taking the modeling industry by storm
she was booked by big-name designers
including Christian Siriano to walk the
runway during New York Fashion Week back
in 2016
she didn't have any runway experience at
the time but she taught herself how to
sashay down the catwalk by watching
videos and practicing in front of a
mirror not only does she want to model
clothes but she also has a love for
designing them she launched her very own
collection of clothing throughout the
fashion retailer boohoo in the summer of
2016
Jordans collection consisted of pieces
ranging from size 2 to size 22 to cater
to women of all sizes
Cindy Kimberly in December 2015
Justin Bieber stumbled across a picture
of a beautiful girl on Instagram
he was so enchanted by her beauty that
he posted her photo on his Instagram
feed with the caption oMG who is this he
had no idea he was about to change her
life forever
his Beliebers came to the rescue and
helped to track down the girl in
question her name was Cindy Kimberly and
she was a teenager from Costa Blanca
Spain her photo received over a million
likes on Justin's Instagram and that one
little post turned her into an overnight
celebrity she had previously worked as a
babysitter making about $4 an hour but
that was all about to change the media
scrambled to get exclusive interviews
with her and her own Instagram followers
eventually surpassed the 2 million mark
modeling scout saw her gorgeous selfie
that Justin had posted and she was
immediately signed to you know model
agency she has since appeared on the
covers of numerous fashion and beauty
magazines thanks to Justin
Cindy's career as an international model
has taken off and she now travels the
world to attend photoshoots fashion
shows and to hang out at fun events like
Coachella
Lucas ABAT Lucas ABAT was raised in
Paris and was always in close contact
with the fashion industry his mom was a
stylist for luxury brands like John
Galliano and Christian Dior and his
father was a fashion designer as a child
he would attend fashion shows with his
parents and he always had a front row
seat but he never thought about pursuing
a modeling career of his own he was
walking down the street on his way to
buying a new video game when a casting
director for the brand hood by air
approached him the man asked Luca to be
a part of the brand's first photo shoot
which was taking place right around the
corner
Luca agreed and that was the start of
his modeling career he was introduced to
Kanye West through his connections in
the industry
the singer hired him on the spot to walk
in his easy fashion show this opened up
even more doors for Luca in the industry
while he rocks the runway and appears in
fashion campaigns Lucca has now
considered following in his father's
footsteps and launching a fashion brand
of his own Danielle Brooke Olli Danielle
for goalie and her mom were asked to
appear on the dr. Phil show back in 2016
to discuss Danielle's out-of-control
behavior some of her outrageous behavior
included skipping school getting into
fights running away from home and
stealing her mom's car
her mother hoped dr. Phil and his staff
could help Danielle change her life
around and they did but not in ways that
the family expected during the show's
taping Danielle got frustrated with the
audience and said to them cache me
outside how about that it was that one
simple phrase that turned her into an
internet sensation
the teenagers phone was ringing off the
hook and her email box was cluttered
with requests from magazines and
websites that were dying to get an
interview with her and that's when she
decided to turn her new catchphrase into
a source of income she started a fashion
collection full of t-shirts blankets
puzzles and ceramic dishes it had her
signature saying and images of a still
shot with her appearance on the dr. Phil
show she was also hired to make public
appearances and reportedly charge a
forty thousand dollar fee brands throw
money at her to promote their products
to her millions of Instagram followers
Danielle also inked a deal to star in
her very own reality TV show do you
think Danielle is deserving of all the
fame and attention she has received let
us know what you think down below in the
comment section Brendon Rowland Fame
came easily for Brandon Roland he gained
popularity on the social media app vine
he later launched an account on you-now
where his videos have been viewed over 5
million times he also posted fun video
clips on the app musically it didn't
take long for his fans to fall in love
with his good looks his awesome sense of
style and oh yeah his head full of
perfectly messy hair growing up with a
mom who was a fashion model Brandon had
connections to the entertainment
industry but it was his social media
presence that launched his career
alongside his brothers hunter and Ashton
had launched a singing career on stage
they showcased their awesome talents
including their beautiful voices their
dance moves and their skills on the
guitar
Brandon social media Fame has
skyrocketed in recent years and he was
even invited to perform at the 2016
magcon tour when he's not uploading
videos of himself on you-now and
musically he spends his time interacting
with over 2 million of his Instagram
followers are you surprised by how
famous Brandon became thanks to social
media jacob Sartorius there are so many
ways to get famous on the Internet you
can record comedy sketches and post them
on Instagram film beauty routines and
upload them to YouTube or show off your
great sense of style on tumblr there are
so many different websites and social
media apps popping up all the time this
is why the possibilities that YouTube
can become famous are even greater just
take notes from Jacob Sartorius he
didn't think much about posting his
short video clips divine and the
musically app he was just having fun
lip-syncing some of his favorite songs
hanging out with his friends and being a
typical kid he always had an interest in
music and he started acting when he was
8 years old these two talents helped him
gain 8.5 million followers on musically
he caught the attention of record
industry executives and he's since
released his own music including the
songs sweatshirt and hit-or-miss while
most people think the way Jacob got
famous is weird the teenager is taking
it all in stride and capitalizing on his
popularity he took his talents on the
road with the magcon tour with fellow
Internet star Cameron Dallas he even
opened up an online store full of his
very own merchandise Daniel Lara Josh
holes fired up his snapchat back in
February 2016 and began filming his good
friend Daniel arum it then turned into a
daily thing for the two friends Josh
would film Daniels outfits and his cool
sneakers as he walked around campus and
he also provided some pretty hilarious
commentary to go along with it when the
internet found out about these hilarious
snapchat stories Daniel
the next big social media star when you
hear someone say damn Daniel back at it
again with the white bands they're
referring to him this saying is now
infamous in pop culture history and the
videos of Daniel and his stylish outfits
have since gone viral after Daniel and
his skaters sneakers became an internet
meme he appeared in a music video for
the band Weezer he and Josh also
interviewed celebs at the MTV Movie
Awards and they were invited to appear
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show and guess
what the talk show host gifted Daniel
with a lifetime supply of ends pretty
cool right but in an awesome act of
kindness
Daniel donated 100 pairs of his lifetime
supply of sneakers to patients at the
Loma Linda University Children's
Hospital in Southern California he may
be an internet celebrity still has a
heart of gold Shawn Mendes many kids
have discovered that social media apps
are the perfect way to grab people's
attention and potentially become the
next big star but Shawn Mendes didn't
have plans on becoming an international
celebrity when he signed up for vine in
2014 he downloaded the app one summer
when he was bored at home and uploaded
six second videos of himself singing
some of his favorite songs he sang tunes
by Justin Bieber one direction and Ed
Sheeran this is how he gained hundreds
of millions of views on the social media
app after a few months he caught the
attention of an artist manager who had
stumbled across his videos before he
knew it Shawn had signed a lucrative
contract with Island Records he went
from singing other artists songs to
performing his own original music it
includes the tracks life-of-the-party
stitches and I know what you did last
summer
featuring Camila Cabello Shawn's days of
singing songs in his bedroom are now
over and he even opened up for Taylor
Swift during her 1989 tour which of
Shawn's chart-topping songs is your
favorite don't forget to leave your
reply for us down below in the comment
section are you a big fan of any of
these kids who got famous in weird ways
react in the comments section and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching
[Music]